qui sait c'est monique annonce n'a pas
roulé la rue de richelieu ah oui c'est
pas du tout dans le coup à fond on était
un opéra ici madame manon et à leur
voyage ah non écoutez on était au pea je
connais bien plaisanter ou quoi nota
palais royal ici oui des jupes à volants
et bien over a quand même si monsieur
justement vous êtes un non voyant et si
vous êtes propulsé pour sa traversée
talent
vous aider à traverser pour vous allez
vous allez droite mandat en fait je veux
dire nous traversons attendez vous êtes
homosexuel pas du tout d'être homosexuel
hanoune on voulait gérer
le matin et vous me jurez ce que je
viendrais versées mais je vais essayer
hommes avec moi allez bonne oui alors on
est là on va la toucher
comment s'appelle ce segment sont
prenants michel michel
a des bonnes en travers alors je lui
propose de lui au travers son travail
bombinette échangiste et échangistes
voilà ce que moi je traverse pour un
montage michel c'est pas possible
e le lou félibre volet louvel est là
mais j'ai rien à faire au louvre par
vous alors là ça devait refaire la rue
par là vous allez allez c'est vraiment
vous faire plaisir ce que c'est pas du
tout ma direction est là mais je vais
opéra j'y suis c'est bon non pas des
royals ont chopé un jeu cassation avant
le changement présentait l'état palais
royal je vous le dis pas les vrais musée
du louvre à gauche pas dans l'avion
encore et c'est ma chance ailleurs mais
pas aveugle alors changé c'est une
expression
la
foulée où je le sache je vois rien mais
tu côtoies ratez pas la donne et des
mois alors
je sais pas vous mais complètement
embrouilles et là je vous demandez rien
ou ne sautez dessus vous commencez à me
faire chier maintenant je vous aider à
traverser parce qu'on sait jamais venu à
vélo c'est plus prudent avec un aveu
passion
pour épeler devant pareil alors vous
avez vous aider voilà que
voilà faites attention à vos seins
[Musique]
le foot est moins la pêche moment où
vous allez vous allez me sall up
mais lâche moi la grappe toi ou tu vois
toi laissé tomber ses pas en braille
le voyant [ __ ] les voyons c'est le
but en attendant c'est le 51 ici non ça
passe à côté ainsi monsieur cheikh
aveugle il faut que je prenne mon achat
prioritaire j'ai une carte de priorité
aux messieurs pendant toute cette folie
b s'est pas offert aux assurés non non
voilées ou par la falaise fera [ __ ]
journée là bas et puis
taxi taxi
avec simon est où là
vous voulez on va chez vous alors
d'avoir huawei on va chez vous
pourquoi
vous êtes de passage à paris voilà ça
vous dirait d'avoir une expérience avec
un non voyant
pourquoi pas mais j'ai pas beaucoup de
temps messieurs et la petite jeune tu
viens et la petite jeune étudiant à
l'hôtel je suis vieille
parlant autant pour moi que j'ai moins
confiance merci je fais trois ans vous
prenez l'autobus et vous descendez place
de l'opéra le cadreur 21
n'importe quel jeu on soude et le faire
j'aime bien avoir touché affaires
intérieures en voiture non
non non non mais je vais y aller non je
peux y aller
merci madame
ah bon ya pas de moto là ya pas une
honda dominator ya rien là on m'a piqué
ma bécane mer mais moi je vais rentrer
chez moi
je dispose d'un espace qui c'est qui
c'est quoi
qu'est ce qu'il ya qu'est ce qu'il ya
monique monique
plas ce qui se passe qu'est ce qui se
passe c'est qui
voilà que c'est soit ça
c'est bon c'est votre cul ça rend chez
votre cul monsieur
vous me conseillez vers un boom dit
qu'on sait vers où nous dit quand le feu
est vert
ya deux pour voulait traverser avant sa
stricte le hockey
le règlement louvre
où opèrent à
la mettra métro louvre ya bien
encore chez rouge l'a
bien
fait pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
l'inaptitude abonnez vous mettez un
pouce bleus